qu'est ce que vous feriez si vous restez
24 heures à vivre un crédit
je crois que je réglerai quelques
comptes quand même quand même près juste
avant de partir et d'avoir un il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont pas soldés encore
il ya encore deux trois bourre pif dans
l'air et ouais il ya 2-3 et une tournée
à faire est-ce que vous avez déjà pensé
au suicide oui une fois en présent non
non non c'était dehors et grâce à la
halle à à la présence d'esprit ma femme
c'est ça s'est pas fait qu'est ce que la
vie vous a appris d'un tapis qui le pire
n'est jamais certain oui
comment aimeriez-vous mourir
bonjour away enterré incinérés un vrai
qu'on va enterrer vivant comment
descendre à non non je m'en fous
sagement complet j'ai pas peur de ça du
touch croyants
j'ai pas fait trop de mal enfin
contrairement à ce qu'on a dit a pas
tellement de gens qui ont souffert et
donc à la fin du parcours je pense
qu'ils me dire allez bien il était temps
que tu arrives et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux